let's go to the phones and see what's on
people's minds it's been a little while
since I've taken phone calls 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 is always the number to call let's
start with 6a - go ahead
hi David this is Thomas
again go ahead - I was calling in I was
calling in to ask you about your
thoughts on the current freak out of the
write when it comes to what I'm trying
to say is Alex Jones he got basically
banned from the internet and anyone with
a working brain just doesn't really have
sympathy for him except for people on
the right who say oh that's a free
speech issue and I'm just wondering
about your opinion on it is it is it
really a free speech issue given that
he's done things that clearly violate
free speech laws okay so it's actually
his violation of free speech laws are
not is not what's at issue here so
you're right to be suspicious about
whether it is or is not a free speech
issue
it literally is not a free speech issue
in the sense that the platforms he's
been banned from are not regulated in a
way that is similar to how government
regulation would support or enforce
freedom of speech so quite literally
nothing illegal happened now there are
some people who are saying yes that may
be true but shouldn't some of these
platforms because they're so ubiquitous
be regulated as if they are government
entities or pseudo government entities I
don't think that's the answer but if you
want to do that there's actually a legal
infrastructure from dating back to the
60s that that would enforce that that's
not what we have so it's simply not a
free speech issue companies have Terms
of Service there are those on the right
who want to pretend like there's some
kind of double standard on the left
saying well on the one hand you don't
want companies to be able to do whatever
they want and now you're saying you do
want companies to be able to do whatever
they want no the question is was the
company doing something legal or illegal
none of these companies have
anything illegal Thomas and right now it
simply is not an issue of free speech
yeah I I already kind of got that they
did a basic understanding of the First
Amendment but like I was I was just
wondering um given what you said about
making it a public utility I also agree
with you on that I don't really feel
like that's the answer because I mean
even even the government given the
government itself it's not really quick
to respond to every single defamation or
yeah I got you know and it wouldn't be
making it a government utility but that
they would be bound by free speech in a
similar way to a government entity but
it sounds like we both agree that's not
what the case should be and I really do
appreciate the call